voilà superbe du cinéma maintenant avec
l'événement de la semaine le retour
d'harrison ford dans danger immédiat il
interprète un agent de la cia un rôle
dans lequel harrison ford semble au
moins aussi à l'aise que dans le rôle de
l'aventurier pascal deschamps et parce
qu'elles pensent le rencontrer harrison
ford qui ne tourne qu'un film par an a
choisi de retrouver phillip noyce le
réalisateur de jeux de guerre et le rôle
de jack ryan l'analyste de la cia héros
des romans à succès de tom clancy
le nouveau volet de ses aventures le
conduit cette fois dans un pays
d'amérique latine où sévit un puissant
cartel de trafiquants
tous trois semblent ans avec des faits
existants ou ayant existé n'est en aucun
cas fortuit
mais le vrai sujet de danger immédiat et
ailleurs chaque roi yan découvre que le
président des états unis lui même a
commandité contre le cartel une
opération armée engageant des militaires
américains et saufs sans en référer au
congrès toute ressemblance avec des
faits existants et caetera et caetera et
tom clancys et bien sûr inspiré
l'actualité des américains depuis l'
affaire du watergate ont toujours essayé
d'être vigilants face aux abus de
pouvoir de nos présidents donc sous la
surface il ya beaucoup d'allusions à la
réalité
ce l'irangate par exemple invités je
n'ai jamais ordonné en quelques mots ne
jouais pas ce petit jeu là avec moi je
ne vous laisserai pas salir leur mémoire
en me faisant croire que vous n'y êtes
ivoirien quel droit
venez vous me faire la morale danse mais
vous monsieur de quel droit quel droit
venez vous dans ce bureau aboyer après
moi comme un sale petit roquettes
je suis le président des états unis
monsieur bien sûr comme on a maquillé
100 films d'action un film de
divertissement un très large public est
allé le voir mais je sais d'après les
enquêtes menées auprès de spectateurs
qu'ils ont bien saisi le message police
in town la vue quelques jours après la
sortie
il a appelé nos bureaux pour dire qu'il
avait aimé le film mais on ne
s'attendait pas vraiment à ce qu'ils
disent le contraire
donc c'est ce qu'il a vraiment pensé je
ne pense pas
le public américain a fait un triomphe
alain tingaud jack ryan pas seulement
parce qu'il a les yeux bleus d'une de
leurs stars préférées
mais aussi parce qu'il fait finalement
triompher le droit et ça vaut bien une
place de cinéma